my name is Shirley Tilghman and I'm a
professor of molecular biology and
public affairs at Princeton University
so I've been practicing genetics really
for thirty years in the late 1980s I
became involved in helping to design the
human genome project what we set out to
do in the 1990s and succeeded in 2003 is
to actually determine the order of the
three billion bases in the human genome
and thereby reveal the identity of the
roughly 22,000 genes in the human genome
that are the the blueprint for
determining who we are and how we work
so I grew up in Canada and from the
earliest moments that I can remember as
a child I loved puzzles and I think
that's what really set me on the path to
becoming a scientist I went to
university thinking I was going to be a
chemist but by my third year I began to
realize I was not sufficiently
interested in chemistry so I went
looking for a problem something that I
thought I could in fact devote the rest
of my life to and that's when I
discovered a very famous experiment in
molecular biology by matt meselson and
frank stahl in which they conducted one
of the most beautiful experiments of the
20th century in which they showed how
the genetic material DNA is replicated
from one cell division to another the
minute I read that paper I was hooked
you